m
vous êtes là j'ai fait bonne route ça va
je vous laisse monter attention à la
marche beaucoup de marche ici bienvenue
chez moi
ensuite on a fait une piscine piscine de
cannes pour dire celui ci né à
légendaire pourquoi parce que manaudou a
commencé je peux faire un petit plan
aussi on a fait mettre des arbres on a
fait mettre des arbres ici la mer on l'a
fait reculer pour avoir le plan pendant
un cadre magnifique tu as to tatou sur
la colline à bata du donnizaux a dû
stallone a dû brad pitt tattoo on a fait
venir un palmier sap allié japonais
c'est pas mieux qu'il ya un million
d'années juste pour dire un petit peu la
valeur du truc hier donc utiliser les u6
en personne rihanna en effet mené en
bateau quoi on a fini en bateau l'autre
île et brad pitt il est venu en hélico
il a atterri dans la piscine juste pour
te mettre une idée de l'ambiance qu'il y
avait je te laisse écouter ça
voilà tu sens forcément le truc quoi et
600 personnes autour ça gueulait sa
gueule et c'est magnifique
hier les woody allen qui est venue avant
de présenter son film au festival on
regarde en streaming à la maison quoi
donc l'avant-première c'est ici que ça
se passe quoi salut monde ils m'ont dit
tu vas bien salut voila
alors ça c'est très simple or ça c'est
une histoire qui nous est arrivé
le gainsbourg qui s'était perdu les prix
en vigueur à l'époque il s'est perdu en
leur poule ont trouvé là ou quoi il a
dans new dawn ici ça va les gars on
s'amuse s'éclate au tarif quoi tu as toi
ma barre a fait quoi dans ma baraque au
vous mais c'est juste cinq minutes c'est
court mais qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
pour y porter pour un petit reportage
tu fais quoi c'est mes potes
ce n'est pas de cannes faille sur
l'approché stival quoi aller
opera moi je n'aime pas du tout
pendant trois mois
m
chérèque
j'y tenais un td ces histoires saisi toi
voilà ces histoires ça c'est de la
graine union grèce